auckland is the world's largest
polynesian city and tongans came out in
big numbers to support their relatives
and friends back home
an aid center has been set up for people
to send food water and other items to
tonga and to show unity and resilience
nothing's gonna
bring our little country down you know
pretty
i guess we have a lot of pride it
doesn't matter what we face as long as
we face it together we'll overcome
anything the opening day of this relief
drive was so popular that many had to be
turned away
what tongans are best at is when
disaster hits we come together unite and
we give what little we have we give it
out of love we give it to our own
families back home it's hoped the first
of the containers will be sent to tonga
early next week governments are also
sending aid new zealand and australian
air force planes landed at the
international airport near the capital
nuku alofa despite some ash from the
volcano still being on the runway
and two new zealand navy ships arrived
carrying supplies divers and underwater
survey equipment to check for any damage
to shipping lanes and the port while the
world focuses on the flow of aid and
helping the people of tonga recover
scientists are also hard at work and
with each day they're learning more
about how significant the eruption was
scientists believe around one cubic
kilometer of material was spewed from
the volcano and sent at least 30
kilometers into the atmosphere so to put
that into some kind of perspective
when we fly
jets
across pacific we're probably flying at
about 10 kilometers with some
communication being restored slowly many
tongans in new zealand have been able to
speak to relatives at home now the focus
of those here is to come together to do
what they can to support their homeland
from afar wayne hey al jazeera auckland